welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and how the hell do Kang variants live
so damn long anyway I mean I know black
don't crack but come on now being able
to be he who remains at the end of time
probably extends Beyond eating your
vegetables and moisturizing daily what
exactly is Kang's Secret Sauce of
Eternal youth in the MCU well using MCU
science from past MCU projects I think
you might just be able to find that
answer together my nerd babies so let's
jump in here we go one two three but
like always make sure to head on over to
nerd riot.shop to pick up one of our new
amazing Mandalorian inspired gear and
also we still got some quantumania merch
including my favorite hoodie of all time
it's so freaking comfortable it feels
good on my skin it feels like a second
skin alright guys so how the hell are
Kang variants like grape juice cyborg
Kang and blueberry blast and mortise
Kang able to live so freaking long in
the MCU like old age is still a thing
right I mean if these guys are human
beings shouldn't they have been born
Immortal and yeah I think this is
actually the case since Kang is a human
being Kang had to have been a mere
mortal with normal human physiology at
first so I think the actual question
here is what changed what changed within
Kang's physiology to allow him to have
eternal life well if we think back to
that moment in quantumania when Janet
and Kang finally got Kang's golden hot
tub time machine working again we
learned that the source of King's true
might lies within the technology of
Kang's suit a suit that Kang
materializes around himself from two
blue glowing rings with a very similar
type of nanotechnology effects
associated with wakanda's vibranium
technology and Tony Stark's vibranium
nanite suit I believe this is
intentional I feel that not only is this
blue energy the main power source of
King suit that gives him his deadly blue
energy projecting powers and his iconic
blue face the last member of the Blue
Man Group to exist in the universe let's
do it this is literally just not funny
but is also the source to Kang's
immortality and the MCU has historically
proven that this blue energy does the
immortality thing time and time again a
blue energy that Nick Fury and the boys
at Shield's Dark Energy Mission facility
call Dark Energy because it's the same
type of blue energy found in the
Tesseract and also 68 of the freaking
universe in our real life which is why
the creative genius known as Kevin feige
in Marvel Studios decided to adapt this
dark energy concept and make it into the
space Stone energies of the MCU and
everybody in the MCU has been going
crazy for Dark Energy ever since Red
Skull and Zola found Odin's secret
hiding place for the Tesseract all those
years ago because people as smart as
Howard Stark knew that this blue energy
inside of that Cube held the potential
of gods in more ways than one this is
Pandora's Box people because remember
when Wen Wu from shungji was able to
live for hundreds of years and build his
entire 10 Rings Empire through his
Ring's ability to channel this type of
blue energy directly into his body and
how when we could create a blue energy
shield around himself with these blue
Rings very much like Kang created a
shield around himself from all those
techno ants that wanted to eat his face
kind of remind you of those wakandan
energy Shields from an Infinity War
don't you think Hmm this is because all
these things are powered by the same
exact cosmic energy source blue dark
energy the secret to Godly MCU
immortality y'all better be writing this
down because I'm I'm telling you the
truth here what's that you don't believe
me you son of a I'm just kidding
but speaking of sons of let's
consider Star-Lord and his terrible blue
energy as father ego The Living Planet
because listening to what ego tells
Peter and Guardians 2 people death will
remain a stranger to both of us as long
as the light burns within the planet I'm
immortal
mm-hmm ego notes that are so long as
that blue light that makes up ego's
brain and his entire being stays lit at
the core of his Planet him and Peter
will be immortal forever this is because
ego The Living Planet is a dark energy
planet and after Baby Groot destroyer of
worlds kills ego at the source you can
literally see that blue energy
immortality leave star-lord's hands
after he openly rejects immortality to
his father and hey if you still don't
believe me consider najma in the
clandestines from Miss Marvel like isn't
it weird how they're the same human age
in the modern times as they were when
they were playing Tomb Raider in
freaking 1942 I believe this is because
the clandestines were actually just blue
nor energy beings within human shells
shells that they cast off when they
interacted with the crack in the veil
and because of this this blue energy
that they called the nor in their
reality kept their human bodies from
aging nor energy is literally just Dark
Energy with a different name from a
different place guys sometimes when you
love a show or a movie it's not enough
to have seen it you need some march to
commemorate the occasion and nerd Riot
has got you covered it's a finale of The
Last of Us left you hungry for more pick
up a lunch of us tea available in cream
or black featuring the logo of Todd's
Steakhouse from episode 8 of the series
don't eat there though just don't don't
do that unless you're a cannibal in
which case Bon Appetit and if you're
stoked for the upcoming John Wick movie
nerdwrite has a whole line of John Wick
shirts to make you feel like you've got
a seat at the high table there's the
Baba Yaga tea a gun Chuck's tea and a
tea for the high table itself
proclaiming I have served and I will be
of service get them now and you'll be
able to wear them opening night and then
also the next weekend when you see John
Wick chapter 4 for the second time and
then the next weekend when you see it
for the third time and the next weekend
you get it and of course if you're
obsessing over the Mandalorian right now
there's a whole line of Mando merch in
the way collection with teas beanies
hats and even stuff for the children we
love the children here have new rock
stars so to get your hands on the merch
that you need head on over to
nerdwive.shop today join the riots over
at nerdriot.shop and I believe it's this
same type of blue dark energy found in
vibranium meteorites in the sea that has
given Neymar the ability to live for
nearly 500 freaking years as well as
gifting the telecon people prolonged
lifespans and regenerative healing and
stuff and let us not forget everyone
one's favorite evil witch Agatha
Harkness of the Salem coven of 1693 that
is a long time ago Agatha the Harkness
is oldest boy like the Salem coven of
1693 was a covenant of witches that used
a mysterious Blue Magic a magic that
Agatha happened to suck out of all of
those witches using the knowledge of the
red chaos magic that she picked up from
the dark hole turning her normally Blue
Magic into purple and allowing her to
suck energy like Elias does or dormammu
does or the dweller in darkness does
like Agatha spent her entire life over
the course of hundreds of years taking
blue dark energy Magic from less
deserving witches and for those of you
out there thinking that dark energy
couldn't possibly have anything to do
with the magic corner of the MCU
false because in the MCU dark energy is
the very power of the gods that powers
the bifrost and Loki literally says as
much with his mouth in Avengers 1.
listen up with the by Frost gone how
much dark energy do the evil father have
to muster to conjure you here your
precious earth like Loki straight up
says the term dark energy and this is
what dark magic is in the MCU and it's
why Heimdall uses his dying breath to
ask the gods for dark matter
coming to us
[Music]
dark magic power for the last time in
Infinity War to be able to summon the
bifrost because remember when Thor tells
Jane science and Magic are one of the
same in 4-1 your ancestors called it
magic and you call it science
well I come from a place where they're
one in the same thing the MCU has been
trying to tell us since phase one that
science and Magic are the same thing so
the terms energy and Magic are
essentially MCU synonyms if you
understand this then you can begin to
understand what makes a witch in what
makes a sorcerer in the MCU which is
like Evan or Harkness and Friga use blue
dark energy Magic and Sorcerers use
light magic from The Source the sun
which is why their magic glows orange
and yellow and yes that's right I said
it here people Thor is half human
because Thor's Mom isn't a God she's
actually just a really long-lived witch
go ahead and re-watch the party 4
episode of what if because Friga leaves
Asgard to go to Earth to visit her
sisters like Friga is a witch from Earth
Odin literally fell in love with a human
like his son Thornton which is hilarious
but anyways the point is Kang in every
version of Kang is a dark energy
scientist it's why Kane can create blue
portals like Thanos did with the
Tesseract and Reed Richards did in
Multiverse of Madness shielding like Wen
Wu and the nation of wakanda and can
blast people away like the Tesseract
Hydro weapons Zola made like Red Skull
discovering the Tesseract in Norway was
akin to him finding a massive Pandora's
box of human potential because ever
since then Humanity has been trying and
dying to figure out the secrets of this
mysterious power and Nick Fury based his
entire career off of this very thing and
it's partly why the world wants riri's
vibranium locating device so badly
because here's the secret everybody this
blue energy this dark energy is
literally what makes Marvels in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it is the
Marvel trigger and it's why all the
Marvels in the movie The Marvels all
have blue dark energy based Powers
because Marvel was a tesseract scientist
Dark Energy literally Powers every Iron
Man suit that they're coming for in
armor Wars It's where Thor's lightning
powers come from it's the source of the
super soldier serum it's the source of
the powers of the heart-shaped herb and
so much more that I cannot even fit into
this video it is the Crux of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Kang being the
master of space and time energy must be
a master of space energy and that space
energy is dark energy and it's the very
reason why kangs like he who remains and
blueberry Pope and mortise Kang can live
for so damn long I can literally talk
about this for days because
honestly Kevin feige is a goddamn genius
and all this stuff is so ingrained in
the entire MCU since the very beginning
since Iron Man 1 it's so smart but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertamed on Twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird and really
fun theories especially more theories on
all these Infinity energies and how they
tie into science in the MCU using the
hashtag the Marvel trigger Theory but
more importantly you can follow the rock
chairs wherever we are on the social
medias and when you do make sure you hit
that notification Bell so you get
notification every time we upload a
video but anyways I love you guys so
much I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign